en medio de este lago Aquí están los
delicados arcos de una iglesia mexicana
de unos 400 años de antigüedad que nos
sumergirá tras la construcción de una
presa en la década de 1960 pero las
sequías recurrentes de los últimos años
han hecho visible sus ruinas al público
que ahora puedes subir a ella sentarse e
incluso comprar comida Los Pescadores
locales es un pequeño Consuelo para Los
Pescadores que se vieron afectados por
la sequía sus instalaciones no son
inmunes a los cambios que está sufriendo
el lago cuando lo que es la corriente lo
que hace que se quiebra y al quebrarse y
al pescado se va como consecuencia del
descenso del nivel del agua Los
Pescadores dieron reducirse en gran
medida la cantidad de peces que pescan
de marzo ya como cinco meses que comenzó
a bajar la presa a bajar a bajar a bajar
a bajar hasta ahorita donde estamos y
sigue bajando sigue bajando la presa la
iglesia reapareció por primera vez en
2015 ya como consecuencia de la sequía
en este momento se podía visitar en
lancha desde entonces la situación
climática en México ha empeorado